hey this is fresh tall Walker in
triangle ABC draw a line segment de
which divides angle B into 60 degrees
and 20 degrees now draw a line segment
CF which divides angle C into 50 degrees
and 30 degrees finally draw a line
segment EF label angle B EF by the
variable X the problem is solve for the
value of x in this diagram by way of
history this problem is known as
Langley's adventitious angles it's also
known as the world's hardest easy
geometry problem because it can be
solved by elementary methods but it is
notoriously difficult to do so can you
figure it out give this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching the
video for the solution there are two
main principles we'll use to solve this
problem the first is that in a triangle
the sum of all of its angles is equal to
180 degrees if we have a triangle where
we know two of the three of its angles
we can use this information to solve for
the third angle because we know all
three angles together sum up to be 180
degrees the next principle is that in an
isosceles triangle we have two equal
angles that are opposite two equal sides
if we have a triangle where we know
there are two equal angles we could
conclude that the sides opposite those
angles are equal to each other
similarly if all we know is that a
triangle has two sides which are equal
we can then conclude that the angles up
is if those sides are equal to each
other to solve this problem we're going
to create a series of isosceles
triangles in order to get to the value
of the angle X and it all starts with a
magical triangle that we're going to
create right from the beginning
what we do is we draw angle BG and we're
going to do this so that angle C
b:g is equal to 20 degrees so I'm going
to real able this diagram that 60 degree
angle we're going to divide into 20° and
40° and these are the angles from before
now what can we say about this triangle
we know that two of its angles add up to
a hundred degrees so the third angle in
this triangle has to be equal to 80
degrees so that the sum of all the
angles equals 180 degrees so this means
angle C GB is equal to 80 degrees now
angle C GB is equal to 80 degrees but
also angle GCB is equal to 80 degrees so
we have an isosceles triangle where we
have two equal angles
therefore the sides opposite those equal
angles are equal to each other we have
BC equal to B G now we know angle C GB
is equal to 80 degrees so angle B ge we
can figure it has to be equal to 100
degrees because a straight line always
adds up to 180 degrees so now let's
consider the next triangle here we have
triangle B ge and we know that one of
its angles is 100 as 40 since all the
angles in the triangle have to add up to
180 degrees
that means the final angle in this
triangle b EG must be equal to 40
degrees and once again we have two
angles which are equal to each other
therefore the sides opposite these
angles must be equal to each other so we
can conclude that sides b g and g e must
be equal to each other now let's
consider another triangle we know that
two of its angles are 50 degrees and the
other angle is 80 degrees so we can
solve for the third angle knowing that
all of the angles sum up to 180 degrees
so we can figure out
that the less angle be FC is equal to
fifty degrees once again we have another
isosceles triangle therefore the two
sides that are opposite those angles
must be equal to each other so BC must
be equal to bf where do we go from here
we're going to draw another triangle
that's in this figure we're going to
have to connect points G and F so we'll
consider this triangle B F G what can we
say about this triangle well sides B G
and GF are equal to each other and we
know that angle G B F is equal to 60
degrees so since all three angles sum up
to 180 degrees we can figure out the
other two angles must be equal to each
other
and there are the remainder of 180 minus
60 so since B G is equal to B F we know
the opposite angles of those must be
equal to each other and there must be
one half of what's remaining from 180
minus 60 so we can figure out that these
two angles must be equal to 60 degrees
so what does that mean
we have an equilateral triangle because
all three angles are equal to 60 degrees
and that means all of its sides must be
equal to each other so let me just draw
this in we have gf this gf must be equal
to the other two sides of the triangle
because we know all of the angles are
equal to 60 degrees we divided this
hundred degree angle into 60 degrees and
what's left over is 40 degrees so now
we've done all this work and we're
almost there so we're just going to need
to consider one more triangle I'm going
to remove information that we don't need
for this final calculation this way we
can focus on the triangle that we do
want to consider where we can figure out
the value of X so in this final triangle
here we know that all of the angles sum
up to 180 degrees
but there's also something else we know
about the triangle is that two of its
sides ge and gf are equal to each other
so this is another isosceles triangle
and we want to remove one of the angles
which is 40 so the two angles which are
remaining GFE and gef must be equal to
whatever one half of 180 minus 40 is so
we have 140 divided by 2 which is 70
degrees so one of the angles is 70
degrees the other angle we know is 40
degrees plus X so we can conclude the
other angle in this triangle must also
be equal to 70 degrees this means 40
plus X is equal to 70 which then means X
is equal to 30 degrees and that's the
value of X so we have 30 degrees as the
value of x I'm going to go back to
original figure and what we figured out
is that this value of x is equal to 30
degrees did you figure out this problem
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel I make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on Facebook Google+ and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at Parker and if you liked this video
please check out my books there links in
the video description